it's a great pleasure for me to be able
to enter
and I were classmates at the military
Notre Dame or both got started is
mosquitoes working together the same
bench or that's a place together many
years starting with back in the myosin
after Notre Dame he went on here to
beach the Harvard one little stories
I'll tell it's after Harvard for his
postdoc he went off to Kenya fact I was
mosquito laughs at Mombasa ice-o-pede
Nairobi and i have to say i went over
visited him at one point to collect
mosquitoes there I think it was the most
wish I say luxurious postdoc I've ever
seen Phil had it was he had a nih
fellowship which at that time is played
I think something like ten or twelve
thousand dollars year and first of all a
bit Mombasa was Kratos the gold mansion
kind of place and action from the place
where you sit there the sort of
mosquitoes when you came to the window
sitting there you look over look the
Indian Ocean he got tired of looking
down to the lake for school and Phil had
a house right on again the indulge in
the beach was right back there and I
think if I recall he had three helpers
he had a gardener housekeeper I think
someone did you have a driver
I think he had at least three people and
this was all on an NIH fellowship okay
and then when the lab got in trouble
financially he was using his leftover
money to help support the research so it
was quite a nice post doctor I had the
Fletcher who visited him anyway since
then he's come back to the US I think
it's been all your time back here in
Florida right since you came back from
from your postdoc and he's been down in
vero beach in the medical entomology lab
girl beach work or not quite as many
years as I've been here anyway he's come
up here to talk to us about ecology and
evolution of mosquitoes probably one of
the leading experts i would say at ease
and ecology you're not so much about me
look at your gauges it's he's going to
tell us about what he's been doing
recently there Thanks turn off this
we'll get to a solid
thanks Jeff that romantic introduction
and reminiscences I didn't really have
three employees working at my house no I
you embellished a little little too much
Jeff but I also want to thank both Jeff
and Rhea do colossal for inviting me
here it's a pleasure to be here and I'm
going to and the first two thirds of
this presentation discuss some of our
work on understanding competitive
displacement mechanisms between these
two species of vectors egypt i on the
left and eighties albopictus on the
right primarily based on our
surveillance and experiments in florida
and the last third discuss field study
in dengi endemic region relevant to
testing whether the competition that we
observe between these species in nature
actually affects dengi transmission in
rio de janeiro are these general lights
okay okay so it's important just to
begin to recognize that both these
species are invasive throughout much of
their distribution and that the
mechanisms that led to the arrival and
eventual establishment of these species
were similar just simply different
vehicles appropriate to different times
of the transport of these species ATC
gypped I having arrived at most of its
destinations outside of Africa through
probably through sailing ships including
those of the slave trade to the Americas
and 80s I will pictus being transported
much more recently prop mainly by these
big container ships so these invasion
roots of 80's egyp tie are based on
research done here at Yale
in Jeff's lab by his postdoc at the time
Walter tabachnick who by coincidence
happens to be my boss at the moment so
you can see how interrelated we are as
medical entomologist and although jeff
has refined this out of Africa design
through more recent research the basic
tenant of 80s gypped I having evolved
within Africa to a domestic form from a
feral Sylvan precursor I think remains
at the accepted convention and the
Diaspora of the species both to the west
and the east occurred differently at
different times the new world being
occupied earlier than the old world
rather the Asian subcontinent the
different colors are meant to represent
different genotypes of the species based
on isozyme electrophoresis done by
tabachnick and powell the arranged
expansion of ADA's albopictus as i said
primarily occurred much more recently
its native range being in asia and at
having a much more temperate
distribution than 80 s egyp died owing
to the fact that there is a diet pausing
stage in this species but not in a tease
Egypt I which enabled it unlike many of
the other congeners relatives of 80s
albopictus to suffer temperate winters
and you can see that both South America
and North America were colonized by
different arrivals from different
locations but approximately at the same
time and what it's also important for
the context of our discussion of biotic
interactions between these two species
is that because these mosquitoes are
both members of the subgenius
daga Maya they have common behavioral
and ecological activities that are
contribute to their encounters both as
larvae in container habitats the
precursors of both of these that occupy
artificial containers such as discarded
tires probably evolved in sylvan
habitats and tree holes and both species
mate during daylight hours associated
with host seeking such as of this human
and this colored pencil drawing and the
sworn at mating occurs associated with
swarming around the host so there are
two points of contact where the both of
the adults and the imagers may may meet
this map of the southeast of the United
States shows the range of Ages Egypt I
in the vertical lines in the brown
distribution prior to the arrival of 80s
albopictus in houston 80s albopictus are
swept rapidly through the range of 82
jipped I and within eight years after
its first detection in Houston the range
of a DS egyptia I was reduced to the
area circumscribed by the yellow lines
with the exceptions of a few large
cities such as New Orleans in Houston
where the in the inner city with the
colonization of Egypt I was not affected
by eighties albopictus these times
underneath some of the cities where ats
the chipped i was wiped out indicates on
the approximate time given the amount of
surveillance done in those locations
that was observed from the presence of
80s egyp tied to the absence so in the
case of Lake Charles within nine months
the eighties gypped I was wiped out by a
DS albopictus and this produced a great
mystery the late Doyon of mosquito
biology who was the leader as Jeff
mentioned earlier this is the leader of
the lab that we both worked at as
undergraduates other individuals in this
audience such as Leonard monsterman and
drillin fish also spent a formative
stages of their career he was known for
a bit of hyperbole but in spite of that
this it is what he uttered here in 1993
publication it was basically true a lot
of people were scratching their heads
about the the mechanism and fortunately
although I was working on other
mosquitoes at the time this happened it
caught my attention and one of my
colleagues at the Florida medical
entomology lab at the time was doing
very valuable surveillance these
graphics come from my recently retired
colleague George O'Meara showing the
occupancy over time of all the counties
of Florida from north to south of the
state by 80s albopictus and during that
period he also conducted a transect down
this highway that cuts through
peninsular florida showing how the tires
that he was investigating for presence
or absence of these different species
shipped i and i will pictus gradually
changed over this period of time to
being shipped i occupied to
predominantly album pictus occupied in
fact by 1994 only two cities still had
any evidence of 82 gypped I another this
is my colleague George O'Meara another
very useful habitats where we actually
not conducted not only surveillance but
was cemeteries because these container
mosquitoes occupy and grow and develop
and emerged in the vases that are kept
in most cemeteries for bereavement and
placing flowers and was it turned out to
be a wonderful grounds for for
experimentation but before I
the leading hypothesis for understanding
the mechanism for about 10 years was the
superior larval competition of 80's
albopictus under natural conditions and
both i and Steve Giuliano with whom I I
shared a lot of research collaborations
conducted experiments not only in South
Florida but in Rio de Janeiro where we
had an association with the colleagues
at the oswaldo cruz institute i'm only
going to summarize these experiments in
which we manipulated in semi natural
conditions larval densities the
autochthonous organic matter usually
fallen leaves that represent the
resource base for these larval
mosquitoes and species in container
habitats and the outcome from both
experiments in Vero Beach and in Rio de
Janeiro was remarkably similar and the
y-axis here is a consolidated a
amalgamated performance index an analog
of the finite rate of increase which
incorporates survivorship developmental
time and an index of fecundity and you
can see that under condition for with
Florida conditions and Brazil conditions
with different genotypes 80s I will
pictus always has a lambda prime above
the threshold necessary for positive
growth but under many conditions
particularly when the competitive
conditions are higher or the amount of
leaf litter as less atc jipped I fails
to meet on those that that threshold for
for positive growth so that was the
basis for quite some time but I'm going
to come in a few slides to a change of
direction but before I do that because I
wanted to present some other information
relative to our studies that I thought
would be more appropriate to an audience
in a climate and energy institute these
are three records from cemeteries which
show three over 20 yeah 22 years of
surveillance which show three cemetery
types in relation to the presence or
absence of 80s albopictus and eighties
Egypt I the top is a cemetery in Little
Havana of Miami where ats egypt i
withstood a brief establishment of a dsi
will picked us in the mid-1960s and has
persisted without competition apparently
from albopictus since that time the next
two types of cemeteries are more
prevalent in peninsular florida the
middle panel showing how the relative
abundance of the two species changed
after the establishment of a tease that
will pictus but the two species have
coexisted for the 21 or 22 years of
observation and the third type is
equally common cemeteries where eighties
albopictus arrived a and AG's albopictus
went extinct and I was not observed
again for the next 18 to 20 years now
those sorts of experiments that I showed
that we're done in tires in Vero Beach
and in cups in the botanical garden at
the oswaldo cruz institute we're also
done in these cemeteries and we could
find no difference in the outcome of
competition in the larval stages between
the coexistence cemeteries and the
exclusion cemetery so that particular
paradigm the effects of larval
competition could not explain the
difference between whether Egypt I
persisted or went extinct so we are
interested in investigating the aerial
environment of the cemeteries because
not only do adult mosquitoes have to
persist but so to do
the eggs which the 18 mosquito is rather
unusual in that eggs are frequently laid
primarily laid above water line and
await flooding for for hatching of the
embryo so we allowed colony mosquitoes
colonized from the cemeteries to
oviposit on these tongue depressors
which were then set in six cemeteries
three of the extinction type and three
of the coexistence type to measure their
survivorship in the same you can buy
these plastic cemetery vases in huge
numbers so they were readily available
to use and the depressors were suspended
in those vases a hole was cut in the
bottom so that they would not flood and
hatch the eggs and then at two and four
week intervals we brought the tongue
depressors back to examine relative
survivorship of the eggs of the two
species in the context of the different
cemetery types we also were able to
acquire microclimate information with
miniature electronic recorders in vases
the outcome of superior survivorship of
80s Egypt I eggs compared 80s albopictus
which is consistent across years of
differential survivorship was not
particularly surprising unfortunately
because of the low power of the
experiment we weren't able to observe
any significant difference between
cemetery type exclusion versus
extinction relative to egg survivorship
however the microclimate information was
still relatively revealing when we put
all the temperature and humidity
observations from the different
cemeteries there are four vases in each
cemetery that had microclimate recorders
we saw that the cemeteries in which 80s
is [ __ ]
I persist were those with the highest
maximum and mean temperatures and the
lowest are relative humidity but as I
indicated we now believe that although
larval competition is probably important
in explaining distribution and abundance
patterns to some extent our emphasis has
shifted to reproductive interference
between these species and another
anthropogenic habitat that we use as
field sites our salvage yards and in the
salvage yards it's very easy to collect
large numbers of in the rainy season
adult mosquitoes with power aspirators
or BG Sentinel traps and although
interspecific mating had been brought up
as a potential interference mechanism to
explain competitive displacement most of
the experiments lab experiments done
were unconvincing to support the
probability that this was an important
mechanism but I was challenged by a
colleague Frederick tropez was now Keele
University in Great Britain to use his
technique of applying PCR diagnostics to
the sperm dissected from spermatheca of
wild-caught females to search for
evidence of interspecific mating and
using collections from to salvage yards
that we sent to Frederick in kiel we
found that five out of 304 individuals
had mated with the wrong species and the
interspecific mating was bi-directional
that is there were 80 s albopictus males
mating with Egypt I females and vice
versa and I should caution that although
although these species
are distantly related there are no
offspring from these interspecific
mating and by itself is very low percent
less than 2% would not seem necessarily
that of significant impact particularly
to explain this huge sweep that a tease
albopictus affected on a tease a [ __ ] tie
however we there was more to the story
we Frederick and I felt that there might
from other evidence be something going
on related to the male accessory gland
products that are transferred during
mating and a normal interest specific
mating so the great george craig whose
picture you saw some slides earlier
probably his most famous contribution to
mosquito biology was identification if
not the substance but the fact that male
accessory glands at mating made females
refractory to further mating so we
performed an experiment in Vero Beach
actually using methods very much like
george craig did debt many decades
earlier extracting accessory clan
products from both male and female 80's
a [ __ ] diane 80s that will pictus
homogenizing it and injecting them into
virgin females both hetero specific and
conspecific and after the females
recovered from these injections
subjected them to mating opportunities
from conspecifics and indeed the outcome
of these trials was very dramatic so you
can see from the the blue bar that
extract from male 80's egypt i did not
affect 80's i will pictus in future
insemination with conspecific males but
a tease albopictus accessory gland
products sterilized 82 gypped I
emails and so we felt that on this
information coupled with the fact that
these mosquitoes were mating in nature
still even 20 years after the arrival of
80s albopictus in South Florida
supported a model that was referred to a
seder ization by the polymath josee
Ribeiro known to many of the mosquito
workers in this audience he's better
known as dr. spit but i think that owing
to this for his work on insect saliva
but um maybe mr. seder also ought to be
now added to his norm de plume the this
this is a little bit of an arcane graph
but it shows in the context of Locke to
Volterra or resource competition just a
small incidents of satyr ization as low
as one to three percent can lead to
interactions that caused extinction of
one species or the other coexistence is
indicated in these squares that are
white but extinction in all other
squares by the by the black and the and
the magenta so if these two species are
continuing to be some patrick as they
are throughout much of the South Florida
the area that I indicated in one of the
earlier graphs one would anticipate that
there should be rapid evolution of
reproductive isolation for them to
minimize the type of interspecific
encounters that effectively sterilize 82
jipped I females so we did cage
experiments with allopatric and
sympatric isolates of 80s egyp dive
which are quite easy to come by in
Florida and no small part because
the Florida Keys such as Key West has
kept 80s albopictus out and as a
consequence 80s egyp died in that
context is allopatric and our hypotheses
was substantiated by these experiments
that is to say female in cage
experiments female 80s egypt i exposed
from an al patrick source such as Key
West or the Little Havana cemetery in in
Miami were more susceptible to
interspecific mating or seder ization
than their sympatric counterparts and
although the converse cross occurs in
cages you can see that it occurs much
less frequently and by the way this
these experiments are not done with both
males of both species present so this is
not a choice experiment the female
ladies out gypped I and the female
ladies albopictus are only allowed in
these experiments to mate with an a
hetero specific male and the you can see
that the logistic regression shows that
female origin but male origin only
female origin was significant male
origin was not and in further cage
studies we showed that one could select
for the allopatric phenotype to the
sympatric phenotype very rapidly in
cages in which Egypt I females were
exposed to 80s albopictus males so
within a few generations the population
which was fifty-five percent or more
susceptible to interspecific mating
could be reduced to 15 or ten percent
susceptible and this is the same trend
in the Miami Egypt I population but
somewhat different initial starting
point
so I think we have established that
Seder ization plays some rule and
there's been discussion among mosquito
control directors in South Florida in
the past five or so years that they're
seeing more 80s egyp died and we in fact
in even in our cemeteries that we
thought were what we called exclusion
cemeteries we were beginning to find 80s
gypped I albeit at very low numbers and
what is not their preferred habitat so
we do agree at this point that 80's
Egypt I is showing signs of recovery in
South Florida and we're continuing to
investigate the relationship of that
apparent recovery phenomenon to evidence
of seder ization resistance and 80s
Egypt I to interspecific meeting with
80s albopictus and I wanted to add one
component one really just surveillance
component to the equation that these two
species do not occupy exactly the same
ecological niche in either the adult or
the the larval stages this represents
principal components of based on habitat
characterization from aerial imagery of
collections of these species made with
over position traps and the heavy
loading for 80s albopictus occurs on
axes which have a high representation of
native habitat earth and vegetation and
represented also with this canopy a and
C stands for asphalt and concrete the
80s Egypt I has heavier loading for
highly urbanized
tats without any vegetation another
study that is still ongoing and
collaboration with my former postdoc
Michael rice ghen who is now on
assistant professor at North Carolina
State were following transects from the
coast inland which also represents a
precipitation gradient and this part of
Florida the coasts are drier and becomes
wetter inland and you can see that by
the color intensity that 80's out a jip
die preferentially was recovered from
coastal areas compared to inland areas
and that particular surveillance was
done in two thousand six and seven and
we compared that with results from the
same transsex surveyed last year with an
apparent increase in the intensity of
the relative abundance of 80's egyp died
from the coast inland which would seem
to corroborate the trends that we're
finding in the exclusion cemeteries of a
recrudescence of 80s egyp died and this
graph simply compares with a simple
t-test the relative abundance of the two
species between those sampling periods
you can see at the intermediate distance
the proportion of 82 gypta in 2013 was
significantly greater than it then in
two thousand six and seven now based on
our lab studies we also asked the
question is say to resistance costly and
the few measures that we had would
indicate that it that it is so the first
bars and these three panels represent
an index of body size an index of Conda
T and index of mating behavior prepares
the allopatric condition with a line
that's been selected for six or seven
generations for Seder ization resistance
the resistant line is smaller produces
fewer eggs and this was this behavioral
index is an indication of what
proportion of females would mate with
conspecifics over a 15 or I think a half
hour interval and you can see that the
mating behavior has changed to the
extent that they are more reluctant to
mate with conspecifics that is to say
they these Seder is a shin resistant
females are just more choosy and would
be wise would be appropriate to avoid a
mistake another index of the probable
cost of seder ization resistance can be
observed in these further cage studies
showing what happens after one has
reached the six generations of exposure
to albopictus and then release the
selection by removing 80's albopictus
and simply letting different lines drift
you can see there is a rapid return to
becoming more susceptible and in these
lines to interspecific mating which is a
another indication of the apparent cost
of this evolution finally just to
conclude this section of the
presentation this little graphic shows
what how I feel or my lab in general
fields are the important factors in
explaining how a TS I will pictus
reduced populations of 82 gypped I upon
its arrival and if you the notations are
confusing the blue represents albopictus
the
read a DS Egypt I we believe that satyr
ization really can be the only
explanation for these rapid reductions
and eliminations in some cases of 80s
Egypt I from situations along the Gulf
Coast that larval competition certainly
is a factor in explaining the
distribution and superior competitive
ability of ADA's albopictus particularly
in rural and vegetated areas but the
different niche favorite favoritism of
the two species also explains how they
become segregated across an urban to to
rural gradient and certainly although we
are doing experiments in different parts
of the tropics as well latitude comes
into play and at different latitudes
there's certainly a an effect of the
higher adaptability a better
adaptability of 80s Egypt I'd to more
tropical conditions and the superior
adaptability of eighties albopictus to
more temperate conditions okay I said I
would wind up the final 10 or 15 minutes
by discussing competition in the context
of dengi transmission the simplest model
of dengue transmission in its epidemic
form in urban environments is a simple
infected host transmission to uninfected
female after passing extrinsic
incubation the virus is ready to be
passed on through biting to an
uninfected host there is certainly this
is potentially a simplification there
may be other factors involved in
maintenance of dengue in epidemic
environm
but what we tested in the field was
based on PhD results of my former
student Barry Alto who was a postdoc
here in fact funded in Paul Turner's lab
funded by a why CEI postdoc and for his
doctorate he investigated effects of
larval competition in the lab between
these two species and included
interspecific competition allowing
females that emerged from competitive
conditions to feed on dengue infected
blood meals and an after extrinsic
incubation period tested for virus
infection and dissemination
dissemination being in our case a
surrogate for capacity to transmit in
the context of their larval environment
and what Barry found was that more
intense competition represented here by
the green and red circles led to a
higher infection and dissemination rate
and eighties albopictus the same trend
occurred in a tease a jip type but was
not statistically significant and in a
further analysis of those data Barry was
able to segregate based on body size and
semin and dengue infection status both
80s albopictus in 82 gypped i infected
and disseminated infections occurred or
more likely in smaller females in both
species so these although in the former
experiment the trends 482 gypped I were
not significant in this analysis they
were so my colleague Steve Giuliano and
I posed the question to our
collaborators at the oswaldo cruz
institute can we
detect or look for a signal of effect of
an higher infection probability in the
field in a d'Enghien endemic environment
this is Guanabara Bay from the mountains
such as crystal don't worry agent or in
the background and this shows the
seasonal pattern of dengue transmission
in Rio de Janeiro so anyone going to the
World Cup will be glad to know they're
not in the peak gun dengi period but we
were fortunate enough to have chosen to
collect our mosquitoes during a quite an
epidemic in 2008 these studies have been
waiting to be published but they haven't
been our this represents our collection
area and what's called monkey house a
neighborhood it actually includes the
oswaldo cruz institute and collections
were done with power aspirators from
domestic habitats expected to have some
dengi infected females we collected from
over 20 neighborhoods in Mangano's and
those with the red stars we found dengi
infected individuals and from those
collections with dengue infected
individuals we measured the wing length
as an indication an index of body size
and individually processed every
collected female for dengue infection
positive or negative we were able to
find 55 dengi infected females which was
enough for us to do a regression
analysis and this logistic regression
did not support Barry altos PhD results
in the sense that this see that the
y-axis represents probability of being
uninfected and the larger females in
this regression analysis are have a
higher probability of being infected
I've included date here in the even
though it doesn't show a statistically
significant p value because it the AIC
value was significantly better including
date in the final model and this 3d
representation shows the effect of
winged link from the probability of
being infected and uses also date of
collection to to add to that model so
I'm going to wind up intentionally
hoping to leave time for for comments
I'm not really see there's any point in
reading the summary which you can do if
you want the main thrust of the
reproductive interference results are
that interspecific mating is certainly
believed by us to be an important
component of understanding how
competitive displacement has occurred
between these species and just
parenthetically we're now processing and
applying pcr diagnostics two specimens
from tropical countries we've already
done samples from Venezuela Gabon and
we're finding interspecific mating
occurring wherever these two species are
meet in nature so I although we don't
have the the type of long-term
surveillance for many of these countries
and aren't able to necessarily show that
competitive displacement has occurred on
all probability we believe that this
phenomenon is occurring
across the globe so with that I'll close
and ask for comments or questions